me traitez moi gaulliste social de
raciste c'est juste immonde
je demande à manuel valls de faire des
excuses au nom du parti socialiste
et moi je ne joue pas au flipper je fais
les comptes et je suis un homme
politique et jean pierre masseret et mon
amie nous nous connaissons depuis très
longtemps je respecte sa décision mais
je la regrette
je pense que si elle arrivait dimanche
il y a trois bulletins à disposition des
cinéphilies pauvres non je vous dis que
s'il y a trois bulletins dimanche c'est
florian philippot qui sera élu l'extrême
droite alors qu'on aura réussi peut être
à faire barrage dans le nord et dans le
sud mais nous n'en sommes pas là on
verra comme les y aura deux listes en
présence dimanche dans l'est
est-ce qu'il doit être sanctionné par
les instances du parti socialiste est
pas mon problème c'est le problème du
parti disent merci par l'association
attend dé nous sommes à trois jours du
deuxième tour de l'élection régionale
on parle pas de sanction la sanction
c'est l'abstention
la sanction c'est le score du front
national nous devons tous y réfléchir
moi j'ai vu dans ma région des villages
frontaliers que luxembourg des gens qui
travaillent au luxembourg où ils ont des
villas que jamais on pourra se payer
nous de des classes moyennes supérieures
il n'y a pas un seul immigré mais le
front national fait des 70 80 % et il
faut enlever la peur de l'immigré il
faut oser dire le mot la peur du
musulman la peur de l'islam il faut
maintenant arrêter de se cacher derrière
son petit doigt
il ya effectivement des effets
économiques le chômage la perte des
réfugiés la crise les attentats ça je
suis d'accord mais en réalité lorsqu'on
discute avec avec du temps avec les
électeurs du front national
il y arrive toujours un moment où ils
finissent par vous dire oui mais moi je
ne veux pas d'islam en france
les dernières heures de négociations
seront longues encore difficile mais
nous sommes sur le bon chemin
la présidence française met tout en
oeuvre pour favoriser l'adoption d'un
accord contraignant universel équitable
un accord qui permette d'enrayer le
réchauffement climatique de le limiter à
moins de 2 degrés d'ici à la fin du 21e
siècle un accord donc ambitieux un
accord qui évite les drames écologiques
et humains qu'entraîne le changement
climatique
le président de la république la nuit
l'instant est décisif il est également
historique je vous remercie
c'était assez surprenant de voir le
premier ministre qui dans un grand
numéro de charme envoyer des compliments
au parti communiste et les communistes
qui ne répondait qui n'applaudit sais
pas c'était assez surprenant
la fracture existent faut pas se mentir
au sein de la gauche entre le
gouvernement et nous la fracture elle
est dans l'application stricte à la
virgule près du traité sarkozy merkel
que monsieur hollande avait promis de
renégocier et rediscuter ça n'a pas été
le cas depuis octobre 2012 oui la
fracture est nette
au sein de la gauche ne faut pas se le
cacher c'est une surprise pour personne
sur les territoires il n'en va pas de
même sur les territoires ont géré
ensemble des collectivités et ça se
passe pas trop mal quoi ça se passe pas
trop mal